hello everybody happy Tuesday I think it
is I'm John Luke and I'm joined by Jake
hello and Matt hello and we are playing
fallout 76 the new wastelanders update
is out today it's that big update that
they promised feels like forever ago
it's supposed to it's supposed to like
rework the main story a whole bunch of
stuff personally I don't know too much
about it I kind of have been pretty
blind had been paying too much attention
so I think we're just gonna kind of
start fresh with a brand new character
and see what's up and then I'm gonna
play with Jake and Matt here and we're
gonna see what this whole game is all
about I guess Jake you've been playing a
little bit earlier today right I have
yeah I played two hours it's interesting
it's definitely it feels more like a
Fallout game I did like right when you
get out of the vault this time you start
talking to people and then they send you
to a bar I don't say too much because
people are about to so you can just go
in guns blazing or you can like sneak in
so it feels like a fallout story I guess
okay I'm just gonna pick a brand of a
face I don't really want to waste any
time on this character trader I'm
leaving the vault that's my opinion of
this game so far
myself there we go beautiful no I mean
honestly no like last time I played it
was with you two guys when this game
first came out right and like we were
like hey we just started the game let's
all attack that deathclaw right over
there and then I was like hey that that
was actually kind of fun just like one
of us dying at a time getting revived
killing a death call it took us like ten
minutes really fun but like I thought
was like remember the best part of the
game first and then there wasn't much
else to it
yeah to see what else they do with this
[ __ ]
it seems to be language I apologize I'm
gonna lower your guys mics just a tad
[Music]
okay so intro seems about the same so
far nothing nothing too crazy
I imagine this isn't really all that
different oh hello Jacob oh-ho Jacob are
you guys already together oh yeah I'm
puking on my shoes as well
alright I'm joining your game John cool
alright how do I join your game shot
Luke I should be on the thing we're
still friends
oh okay here we go so the the special
stuff actually comes into play now so I
guess I should go charisma right well
also I should focus of that perk that
gets us more XP since we'll be on a team
together
okay all right I am in your game server
jean-luc cool
gentlemen cats your mic my mics actually
been fixed if you're referring to my mic
issues I was having a week ago I have
since fixed those all right Kenny JSI
the other scrolls in Fallout ip's in
good hands with Bethesda do you think
another company could handle them better
hmm
I mean I'd be interested to see like
another companies take on fallout but I
kind of like I don't know it's Elder
Scrolls is Bethesda in my opinion yeah I
mean but Elder Scrolls was made by
Bethesda I understand fallout because
the way originally made by them hey
what's up I see you guys we're all
together on a team yeah but like the
fallout everyone loves was Bethesda like
I I like those early games but like a
depend depends who you talk to upset I
don't know but the majority of people
who love fallout in today's worlds love
it because of Bethesda or obsidian I
guess but obsidian like but Bethesda
started modern fallout the way it is
today right and you know they tried
something and it didn't work out at all
no not is nothing close you might like
this somebody asked do you have to why
no game side there we go I think it's
just really low for some reason somebody
asked if you need to start a new
character you do not I just wanted to
start a new character because I wanted
to see how it changed the beginning and
also I hadn't touched my character in
almost two years and I don't remember
anything
about them Jake why'd you decline my
team invite I guess it turned out I
thought I accepted it but I didn't know
what yeah I did accept it
no no magnet accept a mine Matt Matt oh
I accepted Jake's or Jean Luc's this
guy's level 394 I know I saw that guy I
didn't even know levels could go that
high I don't know how to join your team
I think if that when you're down in the
conversation I can read about you okay
so yeah they're already like straight up
there's a dialogue tree can you guys
like interact with that character while
I'm like can you beat him up or
something can you talk to him mom doing
stuff oh the robot the robot guy yeah
I'll hit it and see what happens I could
see you alright well I need to turn on
subtitles okay
I'm gonna invite Jake again girl hey
what up it's real people in a Fallout
game what the hell do I go to accept it
right now how did you just pull out a
machete I mean to it let's go so what
else I got tonight still no game sound
uh let me check this stream I just have
chat happen I I can hear game sound and
I am seeing the game sound levels on the
stream so that is bizarre it is very
quiet right now
not getting any any weird I'm gonna lie
to this person cuz why not
that's right did they hit they had
people the first thing we do is widen
yeah this is followed after all let me
let me let me check it might be you know
it's entirely possible the game sound
could be like really low that's weird
the game sounds like all the way up and
you guys really can't hear any of that
that's crazy
yeah I didn't hear when I was checking
it on the stream hey Ritchie at least
your voices are nice to listen to you
thank you
uh oh right right okay I'm starting to
remember how this frickin game works all
follow games I mean
that's really weird I don't know why you
guys aren't getting any my sounds I can
keep troubleshooting it a little bit
while we we go off look at us exploring
the great unknown of West Virginia oh
yeah I don't have a weapon
Oh wonder if I can give you one I've got
I've got a bunch of weapons so long she
was supposed to give you a machete oh
it's probably cuz I lied to her oh I
lied to her too though you have to ask
for it here I can give you uh here who's
that guy
hello I have to sell its free-radical
I'll just go get it from her it's fine
oh I can set it for zero I just go get
it
hey let's get him let's get him yeah
it's kill him oh dude he's gonna kill
him yeah very fine I'll still give you
the bat spare weapon God oh [ __ ]
John stood yeah and guess what in my
house I have the spike baseball bat -
okay here we go you jumped to
conclusions
this is what happens okay I want to
favorite that I want to favorite that I
think I remember that's how it works sup
sup let's go look oh man this looks cool
here we go
[Music]
stop man oh you know what I think that
guy was not a real person
no he wasn't yeah I was yeah well
actually no I guess there was he had a
level he did I yeah I don't know the
difference but I know that guy was NPC
because the same thing happened to me
when I started up the game I saw him
sprinting up the hill and killed them oh
nice so uh where we going we're going to
go into this in okay yeah oh god I
forgot the team is a lunch brand and a
hunger meter man people are so cynical
about this game for good reason but I'm
like I like hope and it's better I want
it to be good I want this game to be
really good me too
yeah I I can't I don't understand how
people can just like always be cynical
I'm never hoping a game is bad
you're a typewriter that'll come in
handy
hey man that's worth some scrap I know
that's what I have to remember like I
should actually be collecting that stuff
because you're like ah sweet duct tape
although I remember in fallout 4 with
the crafting stuff I got so tired of oh
there's a bug here no a tick I got so
tired of like collecting uh stuff that I
just use console commands and give me
all the crafting materials I needed and
follow for yeah I think that's cuz it
was just like this doesn't really fit
the game but it's here anyway I just got
an indication there's a beaver
oh wow this rain has done a number to my
frame rate we'll turn it off then dams
all right this'll work man where'd you
find that gun John she gave it to me
what she gave me a nice she gave me I
use I had I used my plus two charisma
and I got a machete and a gun oh it's
already working the system alright
there's like the overseers camp up ahead
right yeah Matt eat it
alright okay okay I guess we're help me
help me angry good work oh yeah all
right
sorry guys well John I literally have no
idea why you don't have any sound I'm
hearing the sound the sound is is coming
through the stream on my settings
nothing's different about it
see why reminds us to make sure to scrap
junk often to save weight that's a good
call now yes cuz yeah you pick up lots
of junk yeah you know I willing to give
this game another shot do you guys get
your Ellen later do you share it I think
we get our own Lu
I think cuz man I both got that spike
baseball bat after I think it's like you
get the same loot you know or you get
different slaughters in when you like on
the ground it's technically all shared
if I recall
hey there's a real person you can't kill
people to your level five right yeah it
won't let you do that to level five or
people can't kill you either so you guys
are safe for me for now here in our
party though kidding can you kill people
in your party I don't remember I don't
know I hope God what's shooting me oh
one of these ghouls okay so now ghouls
huh scorched no game sound and screen
tearing oh here hold on let me I can
maybe fix the screen tearing oh no that
made the framerate worse hmm well
nevermind maybe just a simple like I
could I could do that I could I can't
give the streamer reset if because I
wanted to be a good experience for
people hold on I need to restart the
game alright we'll be waiting right here
for you
classic you know what I'm going to also
restrain you restart the game the
graphics settings kind--
reinitialize themselves says their
scheme sunt huzzah we did it uh okay
that was weird I've never had that
happen before but let's just fix my
resolution which is now bad for some
reason
[Music]
cuz it's probably too loud now once the
game is reset what oh my god I forgot
that was a thing oh that you have to
like change settings and then you have
to reset the game which is like okay so
let's do it one more time yeah so sorry
about that guys with the sound I guess
that was a weird issue with OBS okay and
then I can just join on you guys
well join on me cuz Matt's not in it
right play with team we've kicked him
out of the party oh I think I'm still in
your party cuz when I load back in it
just says join on team yeah same here
play with team that's tight that's cool
I like that does this game still have
the battle royale mode it does it's on
the menu on nuclear winter we should
probably try that I never I never played
it I never played it better then someone
was really into it in the office oh I
think it was Kurt I think Kurt was
telling me how like he got weirdly into
it hmm
sounds like a neat idea I'm just worried
about doing anything competitive in this
game with it's like controls and what
right how buggy it is or was who knows
if it's I I have again I haven't kept up
to date so far I've only seen one like
pretty funny bug where I was just able
to walk through this trailer for some
reason like it just didn't exist
sound we all have it now I'm searching
for world searching for world surely now
I joined a bomb I'm a geek we're gonna
cancel this Matt Padgett left the team
you hate to see it oh here it is you
play standard open worlds private worlds
and then battle royale yep it's a
separate mode emits is it's actually
very good as a PR mode it was made by a
different studio interesting I don't
know if there's a single-player mode I
kind of I mean you can play this story
by yourself but if you want to go on a
server by yourself you have to pay for
fallout first or whatever it is I'm
gonna have a private server okay this is
new so they added this little like house
that's not looking come on inside well
here let me go to the overseer so I can
get like a bunch of crap oh yeah I
shouldn't whoa I have a decent amount
stuff
right you can like crafts okay go craft
a weapon
give me back Oh sixty machee Thanks
now I'm ready to play oh you're not Jake
me a chess piece level one it's all
coming back to me all right
let's prepare some stuff here what the
hell did I get that
all right there we go not bad
alright I'm back in Jake's world
really sure where Jake is I see yeah and
he spawned back where he left I'll come
to you guys there I sent you a team
invite I'll go talk to these people
medical supplies Wow
Oh interesting team only interior
private area that's unique to your
character all you your teammates can
enter oh so that's how they handle like
major story characters so you can't kill
them yeah it seems that way
making importance first thing I tried to
do is kill have large consequences
progress is saved less frequently when
in a solo interior be sure your
questions they can check funny before
leaving that sounds spooky alright let's
try what up dude down the gun fine don't
keep craft ammo you can if I recall no
one pulls a gun on me in my bar hey you
want to see if there's a tomorrow then I
want
geez just fires blank syringes just kill
the man all right how do you craft a
elbow you know yes I was trying to
figure out maybe we need you might need
a recipe for it first
why did you just shoot her in the face I
could try it
can you try it why don't you come over
here I did it didn't like me who didn't
let you yeah I totally doesn't all right
[Music]
we can kill this guy right here relax
oh we can kill this Bessy which treasure
can you not join in good it said it
would allow his teammates in okay weird
language but tinker station it's a
different station I just can you hear
this conversation that's happening
between us the register no weird how
does it show like my dialogue it just
shows you aiming at her I want to see
you guys have a conversation it's gonna
be interesting just agree in to lend us
a hand and a little oh okay okay I can
see you now that's cool
that's the fallout experience you know
sir says y'all seen these NPCs makes me
a little warm inside I'm just wondering
how many there are and if there are a
lot of bugs yeah I'm not sure what NPC
was talking about a town in the game so
I don't know if it's like a town you can
go to if they're just referring to a
town outside of this area I should try
and find it right yeah
how would you grab the attention I'm
getting this question wants me to go
murder a bunch of bandits yeah so that's
that's the one I'm on I've done a little
bit more of it now I'm having a
conversation with you it's like really
jarring on my screen like I'm having a
thing with her and it feels like I'm
just playing like a single-player
Fallout game and then all the screen
says yeah there it has even good school
it's a bummer I definitely want to like
restart this on my own because I want to
like pay more attention to the dialogue
it's really hard to get invested in
dialogue when you're playing with a
bunch of friends or doing other things
you'd remember when we tried to play
Elder Scrolls online together and that
just didn't all works for that exact
reason like the attractive book
yeah but then you have your friend next
to you being like let's go kill [ __ ] for
like ten minutes for the next talking to
this cat guy the game's not bad but at
least that story experience of that does
not work with multiple people which
makes it kind of weird as an MMO I can
milk the Brahmin look from it alright
you milk that Brahmin I'll milk this
hair I already move them stay on your
Brahmin mister oh you little fox I could
kill you you stole the milky bastard
you don't want it anyway alright where
are we going what are we doing
you're the leader so I'll change you
just pull up the map and it said like
hey do you want to go the atomic shop
and I'm like no I super down oh yeah I
mean I guess I should do a quest right
Hunter for hire yeah so I can help you
with this is the one I'm on I'm not too
much further okay guys get that cluster
have to go talk to that lady
yeah all right I'm gonna do this real
quick oh it doesn't just give it to you
because I'm the leader it said that you
completed a quest and I got bottle caps
for it but it didn't do anything else I
have to go build a weapons bench at my
camp all right well how do you put on
your camp again so you pull out your
pip-boy and then hit oh right yeah move
camp that guy who's holding a gun to the
bartender gets shot by a do to hide it
record it
Oh way like resets the whole scene for
you that is amazing that's interesting I
wonder if you had joined to me at the
same time if it would have been
different I don't know that's so weird
okay now I need to build a thing well oh
god what is she gotta build that sign
okay sure
perfect that's beautiful nailed it you
just do me a running around yeah okay
load broadcast tape into it
all right into a radio tower yeah it's
it's to the southwest oh I see it so
wait we'll wait for Matt a sec yeah I'm
just skipping through all this yeah
that's not what I did if you need a
refresher good ol Marty Martin fingers
got exactly what you need I at least
appreciate that they let you listen to
the I don't think all those girls would
let you listen to
your friends dialog maybe I'm wrong I
just might yet adding an experience
feeling very very weird I think I see
Matt running over here it's it's a monk
Montauk about geez look at this gun okay
this guy's uh seems cool
oh no one cared
all right cool wait yeah they're not
upset I guess not you're not you're not
mad all right let's go okay let's get
this guy now this person pull out a gun
first thank you got him all right hey
this guy just walked out all right get
him right in the face
muggins just watching us he's like ahh
look at these level three okay
Matt do you need to make that sign as
well oh okay yeah read that sign
mm-hmm nice I'll do that
cool I read it
oh yeah I need to build a camp closes I
was in hiring the subsurface scattering
on that guy's face before I got sorry
sorry let's bring it in everyone's fun
nah man that's follow somebody six you
make your own fun all right how do I
build my camp
pull out your pip-boy and then there
should be a little option out is this
green circle how big my camps gonna be I
think so
I can't even place this camp anywhere if
it goes my camp yeah you're right next
to John Luke's can't oh my god why can't
we all have the same camp buy your own
camp all right let me go across the
river
here we go oh man you getting irradiated
I am trying to find a camp this is kind
of a mod scene I know like wasn't part
of the thing with the private server is
supposed to be Casa do mods wait I think
I just placed my camp but I
[Laughter]
[Music]
what you just got placed assignments all
you gotta do oh okay there we go
okay so now you have to go to the
broadcast station alright I'll follow
you guys cuz I don't have this on my
yeah I'm just gonna follow you guys oh
what the heck just hit me
Oh a dog hi nice
all right this way I believe
I actually did put a decent amount of
hours into this game I feel like I
didn't finish it but hi I got to like
level 30 dang that's but what more than
I did I got to level 11 I think I got to
10 and I was surprised that I got on
that road over here yeah we played a
fair bit of this actually yeah I think
we played a couple nights there wasn't a
lot to it if I remember correctly yeah I
just kind of got bored who iguana bits
my favorite snack
I never got to like the ability to to
nuke or anything like that I never like
did the end game or whatever that means
by the way I should mention we're all
playing on Steam the game officially
came out and steam now and I believe if
you owned the game already and you had
your Bethesda account linked to your
steam account it would just give you a
free copy of it on Steam yeah they
actually extended it to April 28 - so
okay cool yeah you can still do it yeah
I don't know if it's related but I also
suddenly had on like fallout 1 and 2 in
my Steam library I don't know if that
was part of it I'm killing the responder
protectron sorry guys
where are ya where are you oh there you
are oh yeah I'm coming
how are these crazy Padgett
hmm
blowflies they're nasty
oh good evening just walk right up to
their face and pop all right use vats
man oh okay how do I activate fats I
know you're using controller right lb lb
okay right right yeah I forgot that this
game has an accident yeah it's kind of
weird
anything here
[Music]
not really anything here unless you want
some eight is some pool balls rake rad
stag radical geek s if it's worth buying
now I don't know yeah I'm doing a video
it's really to say America no new videos
I'm gonna play more this week and get a
video up about that question see if it
is worth coming back to or trying out
now it is $40 which I don't know if
that's for not it's cheaper than it used
to be at least like I paid $60 for this
game like a sucker I paid 80 canadian
dollars for this thing and was like
immediately frustrated that I did hey
but at least you get two copies now yeah
that's true kind of two copies of the
same game on the same platform and you
don't even know Nate because all DRM oh
yeah
some rooms out here but I guess this guy
kill them all so live broadcast day but
wasn't giving me an option to load a
tape then oh I just wasn't paying
attention
yeah I mean even though like I I played
fallout 4 I'm still like every time I
play a follow game I'm still in the you
Vegas remind of how that works
oh yeah you can't do that you'll just be
disappointed yeah like you know what so
like a lot of people chatter or a little
wary but this game has a community that
loves this game it's true
I'm just gonna faster on the back and I
can feel annoyed when people on Twitter
just dunk on it even though they haven't
played it since lunch is because there
are tons of people who love this game
and have fun playing as games with game
says in the chat totally hot where are
you okay
I just fast traveled back to my my camp
because it told me to go there for I
think since there's three of us we just
charged this bandit camp together and
you guys figure out where it is whoa oh
yeah dude let's do it where's your gang
tell me or I'll eat your eyeballs I'm
saying that I'll kill him um give me the
word what can you tell me about crane
I'm gonna get some info out of him
then then you can kill him for the same
last time I saw him he mentioned
something okay ban in storage
factory your guess as good as mine all
right kill him kill him
kill him I can't what I can't I can't
did he kill now no all right I go I go I
could kill him oh he's got a lot of
stuff to yeah it's them those 44 right
yeah I'm taking all of it
I got a drink water all right I'm coming
to you guys I don't know what I'm doing
at this sign you gotta wait for someone
to come up and talk to you oh yeah but
he walks away after I did that I'm still
getting the same notification was that
not the guy oh yeah okay there's another
guy oh yeah hey what up I want to join
your crew have we trade now I'll just
attack him oh shoot you're gonna fight
alright let's fight
okay I got a note all right hey man no
no that's kind of like an ad yeah are
you going no no we're good you go home I
I'm gonna go back to the bar and talk to
the lady god damn that guy was uh was a
tough one I oh I think I'm injured
all right this random curfew yourself
dead oh okay like that all right
well you don't look to words huh bring
me your finest flannel it's over adding
is not bad so far and that's of concern
why exactly
Gabriel Schultz says it may not make
sense for everyone but now feels like
I'm playing a fallout game yeah that's
kind of like Mike after two hours of
playing that was kind of like my first
takeaway it was like okay this is even
though it is kind of like a weird
multiplayer sort of hybrid it feels like
a fallout game which is good yeah that
two bandits just showed up yeah I turned
them against each other and then I
killed both of them
excellent that feels like follow yeah
that's another coot makes a good point
is that the Steam version isn't like a
Ubisoft game where it then boots you
play like it's just yeah yeah which is
awesome I wonder why they uh they they
kind of back pedaled on that maybe just
a digression cuz doom still uses the
Bethesda launcher if you buy it on or I
mean like you can buy it on the Bethesda
launcher yeah it doesn't it also doesn't
make you load load it up though if you
buy it on Steam on Steam now oh that's
cool
because I remember the whole reason they
were like putting it on their Bethesda
launcher is because they had more
control over like server and customer
support that was one of the things they
were saying but I guess you know at the
end of the day you'll probably just make
a little more money selling it on yeah
alright okay so I have many options I
can either kill the gang leader convince
the gang leader to leave the wayward
alone question the family at the farm
question the scrapper at the County
Fairgrounds or fast travel back to the
vault
well fast trailing back to the bowl is
just it wants you to do that to show you
how to do it and because it's closer
oh um so if you want to complete that we
might as our just fast travel back there
now where's Matt I believe it he's
talking about your inside okay alright
let's go
I will do that as well guys know what my
fallout 76 canvas bag this engine is
super old yet is really old but I hope
and I think they said starfield that
they have a brand new engine for that
which it's it's time it's a bummer
because I think there's there's good art
direction in this game by the game can
look beautiful at times yeah it can
definitely get muddled under the the the
rough engine armor these guys
seen a lot of handsome love in the chat
I love it yeah you like to anthem Oh
quite a bit Matt the end game was oh my
lord but other than that I really like
to anthem yeah I remember you and me I
remember we we tried to engage a little
bit in the end game I think you did a
little more than me but it just wasn't
that much there it was a herd game to
play I did not hate my time with anthem
but I definitely it was a game that I
played and as I played it I was like man
this could be so much more so yeah I
guess just fast travel to the vaults
Matt when you're ready sure I will do
that and then I have to go to the
bathroom no worries I forgot to do that
before the stream toggle uh-oh
oh I untitled it that's nice
all right
is that guy trying to kill you oh this
guy's fighting me oh no man you can't
fight that guy look at him oniy under
attack go away oh god oh god
are you gonna help my friends we're not
gonna build to do anything just ignore
him
I know did you fight back all right I'll
be right back
Oh oh my god oh my god Wow all right
good lord
that guy was level 69 well a good thing
it's a free respawn at the default 76
[Laughter]
so I didn't realize that so if you fight
back then that initiates it yeah yeah
all right let's uh not fight them this
time the bolt off cocktail yeah rematch
I can take them
[Music]
I mean you know if I spend 150 hours of
it ever to get this high of a level and
fall out 76 I feel like I'd want to you
know grieve some new plays yeah I can't
blame them
oh no definitely not can't blame them
[Music]
are you inside the vault no no no okay
we're heading to the farm
all right I'm coming to you guys
my trusty bat
my Xena division where people would run
in front of your bullet seed go rogue
and may kill you
oh I remember that ad system in the
division it was so weird it was kind of
fun but it like makes total sense that
it's not there anymore
I really preferred the dark zone and
division 1 over 2 personally I thought I
loved to so much wholly oh yeah yeah
you're a huge fan of - no - good she's a
good game I really want to play more of
it did you did you play the expansion at
all
I have not current events did not make
me want to play a simulation of current
that's very fair I do really want to
play that expansion though girls eyes
are missing holy cow ok now they're back
ah dang this guy knows something but I
can't shoot I should have hold on maybe
I can
cuz save scum well I was gonna say I
still need to level up so maybe maybe I
can put more charisma points in what's
my joke alright
yeah but no it's going to Chris my
[Music]
oh heck yeah all right then we endurance
QB gaming ones proper fallout 5 I mean
ya do too but I much I want to know this
girl's game so bad yeah I'd rather get
over his girls first like even when
fallout 4 was announced I was like for
the other schools all right I don't man
I like Bethesda's games I'm not one to
long for them I mean I didn't think I
was either until it took and except now
it's been almost 10 years and don't
having a new Elder Scrolls game oh I
guess that's a really long time like the
wave between of living from Skyrim was
fine it was like 40 noes 5 years or
something like that like I don't think I
was like are I need another one so bad
but it's been right an insane amount of
time I bet you we won't get other
scrolls six-and-twenty into like 2022 Y
star fields definitely first right yeah
start fields first at all I imagine I
think it's gonna be launch window for
the new consoles I don't think it'll be
a launch title but I better go come out
early
what's an oblivion a launch title it was
supposed to be it didn't make it it came
out a couple months after that was one
of the games that convinced me to buy a
360 Virginia what a game that was - ah
so good
all right so I talked to this guy and he
gave me some info I was totally able to
like leave the conversation level up in
the room again all right should kill
that gang leader I think we should kill
that game yeah let's do it right oh yeah
let's do it
forget about convincing him to do
anything let's just kill ya we're no no
yeah we're gonna kill him let's just
kill him
eighty-six the Mad Hatter is the Elder
Scrolls online anyway decent I think
it's definitely alike it it's a decent
game and a lot of people like it I think
the issues we were talking about we're
very specific to us trying to play it
with each other and like feeling like
that with that narrative dialogue just
wasn't really working when we were
trying to play in a group but I get the
feeling I would enjoy that like by
myself more which is kind of weird cuz
it's an MMO yeah I feel the same way
yeah I mean people love that game for
sure I really into it I think they just
added like a big expansion that is like
adds a bunch of Skyrim stuff to it
yeah which once again is like I don't
need more Skyrim but as way more
interested in the expansions and they
were like Somerset and yeah yeah like
places that either you haven't been in a
long time that I've never been to what
was the last one they added Africa
barely but it's like where the Khajiit
are like the black Marshall yeah yeah
like that's cool to be fair I think that
Skyrim stuff's like a smaller because
Skyrim was already in the game so I
think it's more than added like new
story stuff to do there it's it's it's
like the dark underbelly of Skyrim is
the theme yeah that's cool I can exact
the black market of scarab I'm going to
the guy all right oh yeah we're just on
different trajectories oh I see I see
yeah we're a little more tough you guys
want to stop at the fairground there's
another thing I could do these like a
scrapper I can talk to sure I've done it
but I am all for it I've never done that
no you have remember what's this
fairground this must have been here and
I just never visited it well I mean I
haven't done it with this character we
haven't done it well I don't know maybe
you did it and forgot about it but I've
never seen this place
all right you sure look what are you
doing man I mean combat coming idiot
people they attack first man whoa now
see that they can keep it they don't
need a Sun a bug it's a feature okay
where's this guy ray supposed upon he's
up here follow me
wow this is scorched hey wait wait one
second oh thank you bright dance
oh here he is whoa oh
here you talk to him I'll deal with this
today thank you oh that's another player
I can't attack the other player Oscar
the scorched you talk to the well-done
guy huh
heat strength that's a lot that was that
guy just making a joke about Stealth
boys me yeah it's like I was like I was
like hey if you got something that'll
make me go invisible music that's
ridiculous nearly invisible makes you
invisible that agile local uh go grab an
egg is that how far out of the way do
you want to do it it's not that all
right yeah we can do it I did it
sure all right
I've followed you I am low on ammo
though oh hi you left some ammo for me
yeah you got three rounds better than
nothing
Oh over here Jake
someone said that you can make ammo at a
tinker's workbench did you find one oh
that might be it might be you need to
specific workbench for ammo
yeah that's what I'm sayin I don't have
any resources to make ammo I recall that
well I probably don't either
pretty tough okay you get like harvest
like mineral deposits in this game let's
skip it's got a lot in it can craft in
it and I can craft arrows
jean-luc are you running to the guy no
I'm running to get this egg for that
other dude yeah but don't we don't we
kill the game leader and then take the
egg no no this is like an optional
element I'm gonna run to you you should
build a fast travel to me for free okay
actually that's called island oh god
let's do it oh I'm waiting for you guys
alright one second absolutely not
oh yeah so I went to that island there
was no deaf clubs there I just went up
and took off I taking the taking the
risk oh wait why what I tried to fast
travel across the river to you and it
just like moved me to a different part
on the other side of the river
excellence you just wants you to soak in
those rats
[Music]
oh yeah death clag's oh nice disease
death clive there's like a dead one or
something just diseased yeah but it's
like a dirt mm-hmm
I say over probably leave before actual
death bras show up
I like that this guy is like he's
following our tracks I'm gonna fast
travel to that guy it's like one cab
yeah I'll do the same
actually I'm not you guys are gonna talk
to I'll get their butts in it well if I
fast travel and spend the captain you
guys could just fast travel for free oh
good point good point good point
Dovahkiin East Scrolls this game is
running at 60 frames per second for me
it's running it's running good for me it
might be the stream it so normally I
have to like change some settings to
like get the stream with my PC looking
good but whenever I try to do that it
caused the framerate until I die I don't
know what it what's up with the game but
the stream quality might not be entirely
indicative of the actual game experience
so if you see any drop frames with
screen tearing that that might just be
the stream 60 pretty solidly okay
differently dips but jake has a monster
machine to ATT I'm you know I'm gonna
you know play with it minecraft or a
tree it comes out in a couple days I
like try it looks good it's so cool I
saw that see yes it's gorgeous dude yeah
I don't know if this is gonna be in the
final build but they do a thing where
you can like flip off ray-tracing and
then flip it back on with a button press
and it's just so mind-blowing that's
cool
all right just talk to him we ready yep
guys we'll be all cut up with me after
this yeah I got the thing I guess I got
wait what I mean I don't have it anymore
so I definitely I just gave me a couple
stealth boys okay follow at 76
peromyscus wow you got the new fall at
76 game yeah
brand new
oh right qualified gamers talking about
when you could look at the ground and
the frames per second would go up and
you could run really fast because oh man
that was like a that's a quick three
strategy right there yeah okay hold on
one second I gotta drink some water yeah
actually I should heal myself too before
we go in here oh you meant the game I
thought you meant in uh in real life oh
I was like okay sure let's go every
watch wait a minute guys I got a glass
of water here I got it
see this appear first
he
you guys sound so familiar um make a lot
of videos on games fun that could be it
you might be familiar with Jake and Matt
from their brand-new Resident Evil
series blowing up on twitch oh yeah
remember when bethesda made actual video
games oh come on this is a real video
game what are you talking about oh wow I
like that I don't think I ever used that
today wow this way [ __ ] better
alright are there more people are always
he gets level 20 I don't think so I
think there's just not a whole lot of
people in these servers yeah to be
honest I kind of liked it that way but I
could be wrong maybe more dude joined
later yeah I like I like the idea of
like because it is small like it's very
rare but you do occasionally run into a
person it's like kind of cool but like
usually nothing interesting happens
other than like maybe they killed it
zib let's is Jake and Matt sound like
fortnight's dreamers bed Taylor the
ginger says for tonight's dreamers are
all squeakers and weeaboos which I was
gonna say yeah I'm gonna shoot this
person you want didn't do anything
yeah well always stead of precious is it
cuz it's a trader kind of buys yeah I
guess there are some people just can't
uh can't kill all right 308 308 no one's
got 308 so I supposed to do
all right I don't know should we sleep
what's the benefits of sleeping I think
it recovers your health and what not
sure oh oh yeah you guys you just laid
down right like do I have to just wait I
think yeah I saw that that animation is
taking forever yeah okay
am I sure I'm waiting in this bed
resting in a bed slowly heals yeah yeah
I mean I'm Marty also I catch a disease
apparently if I hang out in this bed too
long disease-ridden beds
guess who sat in that bed before you
show up no no the farmhouses were headed
I guess so whew that's taking a hot
minute to load in on my team Wow here we
go oh yeah it looks it's not a real
player that is hey yeah I think that
guy's doing the same question to us
I've seen him before is it the answer
nerd yeah
how are we doing this I should be
Russian
I can't we Russian him we spell sheet
gun turret I think we just rush them
dude oh here there's a door over here
pump his belly full of blood
good never mind is not a door wait wait
what if we talk our way in get to him
then kill him and shoot our way out oh
that's a good idea
all right I'm all for that who's got the
highest charisma John Luke you do don't
you no I think I do all right
what's that Matt's right I'm here got a
delivery lead and lots of it got
something to say I think you see you in
Hell now that Matt alright well dad
guess we have any ammo they're not
attacking you know this guy what man
alright let's just walk up to the gang
leader and fill his belly with a lead
baby you pregnant him with a led baby
baby talking bullets asking do you guys
stream outside a game spot by the way
nah I haven't streamed of a really long
time ever since I started working at
GameSpot I know if you guys stream
regularly though right you but Matt and
I were streaming arrested and evil but
we finished resident evil 3 we're gonna
finish Resident Evil 1 oh cool
you guys should play the whole series oh
wow hey there are guys in here shooting
at me
alright guys
oh it looks like engine oh wow I'm
getting shot from a couple different
angles
where are you guys I joined the solo one
because I wanted to make sure that my
quest progresses yeah that's a good
actually a really good plan to be honest
all right oh well a laser oh [ __ ] put
that on I'm shooting free radicals right
now hey hey chill
calm yourself my dude go oh I have to be
level five boo that's X let's stuff to
do in here though there's a button that
automatically uses stimpacks wasn't
there
yeah I'm a little confused killed I
thought I was killing the gang leader
oh there's downstairs
oh man I hope the next follow game does
something about the menus oh yeah I'm
pretty over the pit boy is that like not
that the menu the menu should be in a
pit boy but the way it looks and the way
it works not great so much to lose all
right guys all the nine holy crap mmm to
have any grenades
molto cocktail
yeah
here we go get them just kind of cool
yeah got him
Oh pump action shotgun heck yeah quit
that ah also level five dang it oh I
died I should play this tape I got
[Music]
where is this crate
all right who should I try killing first
Roper or his buddy Oh God
all right here we go oh nice
whoa they took turns trying to kill me
nice very polite of them I love Paulo
like the Janki is part of why I like
this game
series I guess I don't know I'm having
kind of a fun time with this actually
hey buddy
oh [ __ ] using a weapon with ammo
oh yeah I almost got it
they're a mess okay hang their bodies in
front of them like put them on up pike
sounds like a good message never answer
my question I just want to get a job at
GameSpot uh you know just put yourself
out there make stuff start start
developing a body of work be proactive
I will say that that definitely comes
across well when when you're out there
making your own your own things
scroll message all right oh that's nice
leave a little note form leave the way
word alone all right
did you guys just do the message
believable oh okay guess who came here
and killed your boss no word 86 the Mad
Hatter 76 do a good job explaining
itself to new players are you gonna
spend some time on the wiki etc just to
get filled in do you mean like in terms
of how the game is played or like
story-wise cuz story-wise I don't know
it's kinda like a fallout game like yeah
there's a lot of lore but you don't
really have to know any of it to enjoy
it I would say I would say mechanically
the game does have a fair amount of
tutorials it's like I remember I don't
remember having an issue when I first
played it it's like understanding it
mechanically necessarily like
quality-wise either but this seems a lot
like fall 3 and new Vegas like how hard
it is yeah I would agree
oh you sure on that flame yeah it's a
trap apparently it's badass
oh wow oh you know what I don't like
this there you go
okay now I'm in a spot of trouble that's
right Jake give me your offerings gas
masks
oh speaking of gas masks Jake I played a
Jeff from the Jeff level that's that's a
good [ __ ] man
oh that games good yeah I'm building a
new PC tomorrow so that'll be one of the
first things I do on it nice what VR
headset you have quests oh cool yeah I
I've been running with a quest and
honestly the the wireless is I just I
just can't turn that down so yeah so do
we just fast travel back to the waiver
yeah might as well I feel like all right
um yeah
does somebody want to do the wayward I
confess struggling you guys confess
travel on you sure oh it's all the way
back to Duchess yeah it's you can find
it eventually it's it's yeah yeah yeah
actually you know what no I could travel
to my camp for free oh yeah do that I'll
do that Oh smart
[Music]
yeah I uh I had to spend this morning
cleaning up my computer because I was
trying to edit and it was just chugging
and I like had to just clean out a bunch
of like old programs and files I wasn't
using anymore
and I was like man I should upgrade I
feel like now it's the right time I was
just did it for cyberpunk I just wanna
make sure I'm ready for that that so
that's that's the thing I've been
thinking about that in the back of my
head I'm like I gotta gotta get ready
for cyberpunk Ram
86 the Mad Hatter is trying to finish
bone works but is struggling to keep
interest in it I mean I think Jake and I
are like we think that game is cool but
we don't necessarily love like playing
that little bit of it and it was neat
but it was just like I don't know if I
wanna play all of it that I feel the
same way about it where I think my
favorite part was the like tutorial gun
range and I thought that was really cool
and then like the rest of it I was like
oh this is OK it's got something ideas
but yeah it definitely feels more like a
like a cool tech demo than like a like a
good video game if that makes sense not
to like diminish the work that went into
it because it is really cool in a lot of
ways
gave him a message I told them exactly
where to find you if you have problems
go here don't don't hurt these people
that just hurt your boss they're two of
the tougher cookie you track him down I
gotta go find some people for her you
could track her with your little radio
there by the way we're technically
running up on when we would normally
stop the stream I don't know do you guys
want to keep going for like a little bit
more in stilettos
yeah time to do whatever why don't we
keep going for a little bit more Oh keep
talking to tuchis apparently I
definitely want to replay this and like
go through more of her dialogue options
I'm just kind of through it for the
stream purposes when I was playing by
myself this morning is definitely more
ideal that way it seems like like I
can't really speak on the quality yet
but like I'm liking the more three new
Vegas style of dialogue in this game
than what was done at four well yeah cos
4 was limited by like you were just
picking like the four different sort of
emotional responses if I remember
correctly like the way it worked it was
kind of weird Adam yeah but my main
problem was just that you were playing a
character and that character was like
already defined by the voice acting
right so that like I wanted to play a
jerky bandit dude but my guy would be
like don't be running around this place
ever again but hate you know what my son
is mm-hmm
it's like we're all playing on PC stereo
entertainment are you guys talking to
Duchess yeah I just finished talking to
her so I'll wait outside
I have to go track some guards down
oh wow I I am where's their traitor
around here hmm good question
oh I'm over five now so I should be able
to have my shotgun and that laser rifle
oh you know what I'm gonna scrap some
items
I thought I got a good craft apiece
armor oh yeah I was getting that
objective - even though I did all that
stuff yeah I like totally did this hold
on I'm gonna do it again what peace of
mind missing
[Music]
left arm
I guess level five now my my biggest pet
peeves with fallout 4 it and probably
with this too is that when you holster
the rifle it didn't show up on your back
oh yeah and like it was something with
like however they tweaked the engine
that was like super because I I you even
try to get there was like a mod you
could do yeah I mean to install that mod
it was just like that seems like such an
odd thing to get rid of right cuz that
was totally in three right yeah weird a
new Vegas I'm like Skyrim - right like
all your weapons on you and like your
pistols wood befitting your rifles but
just like you just pull them out of thin
air and I'd be like come on at least I
always liked putting on I remember it
like fall 3 I would get mods I was like
add like just bags to you like you to
have like a like an ammo pouch like of
it like a shotgun like ammo and stuff
like that just to make my character look
more realistic yeah I loved adding like
mods like that to the game crap the
weapon i guess i hatch it
oh yeah I've got a stash boxes hell yeah
all right all right weapons let's drop
that in there
fire axe holy cow yeah this one guy just
says fallen for his dialogue option was
just yes tell me more and yes
sarcastic yes and no but actually yes
yeah yeah I kind of remember that like
it was sort of like that was the only
response to like quests and stuff they
was really limited okay it does do I
need here you might fit boy let's do
that
Oh
[Music]
all right that's good start to get a
hold of this inventory stuff yep it's
all going back all right let's find some
music
[Music]
oh I have to keep the thing on or I
can't never mind
on open perk pack Thanks luck luck luck
would be good is this like extra ham oh
yeah that's actually a good idea I think
I'm gonna do that
cuz I keep running out of 308 this menus
knock on an awesome keyboard I'm
actually really into the UI with
controller feels good it definitely
feels clunky on a mouse a keyboard and
we I need more ammo pretty badly accent
whoa Jacob nice what nice god dude so
how'd you get that don't worry about it
don't worry about it you cheated
microtransactions oh I got one of those
too man George get that join our schools
we can't leave the club why would we
tell you man come on how'd you do that
what we all need we all need to be on
the same page in this game in my opinion
if we're all gonna have a fun time as
friends well I can craft a regular
hunting rifle now I'm gonna do that all
right
are you guys ready to go do this quest
well let me craft this hunting rifle I
just I checked my notes and I had a
recipe for it oh yeah you gotta like oh
wait I can't craft oh yeah I have that
too
modify now can I not do it because
you're currently using the maybe but it
doesn't even look like I can oh
machine guns here we go oh never mind I
guess I just it was just a short hunting
rifle
nobody had one of those I don't even
craftsmen that's all right let's go then
are we going oh great yeah this game has
a really interesting like skill tree
idea where you like stack cards oh yeah
I like the idea mind it I think it's
kind of neat yeah yeah cuz I gotta
balance it right yeah it kind of lets
you like swap characters on the fly and
cuz you can put points into like
teamwork stuff but then you can take
them out when you just find out yourself
I dig it hang it's an interesting system
somebody's asking you I've tuned by my
radio yeah should be this way okay I
haven't done that yet oh yeah how do you
do that you go to the rail somebody's
asking if we have played it before so
yeah we we all played it at launch we
actually played with each other a little
bit like I said I think I put like I
must have put at least 20 25 hours in
this game because I'm like level 30 or
something at level 30 character I have
but I never finished it and I and I
haven't really played it since I've
initial like week or two so I can't
speak to how this game has been updated
over time use this signal to find the
Duchesse cards how do you use this thing
to find it so once you activate it and
you pull up the map there should be a
little spot on your map I'm heading to
it right now
okay I was okay yes yeah
I assume it's right up here y'all need a
loop I like it yep that's me frame rate
John detail eek okay I think it's a
these guys got a production log for a
mind okay we're gonna do a mine I guess
it's fine time get my light on search
golly mine I think I remember looting
this exact mine with you guys oh you
know what I think you're right yeah
we'll be played back in the day this
like rings a bell
just leaving it 38
I picked that up I know I did to do a
review of this afterwards well
definitely not us we don't review games
for GameSpot I'll be doing a video
though about whether or not it's worth
it you know kind of review but also not
really review do you do you know if
we're doing like a updated review or
anything
I think someone's gonna take a look at
it to see I think Edie probably cuz he
reviewed ram ocean which got off for
it's not often that big Triple A games
score that well yeah you guys understand
I did this mind by myself okay I'm also
by myself is there a way we could not be
together we can how do you make and I
are doing it solo just in case we don't
well I guess we could do it together so
what happens is you have to enter the
mind and then we can press a on a door
instead of X and then we'll join you
so it didn't even give you that option
oh really
well did you enter wonderful that was
the first one in yeah yeah the first one
in here why don't I leave and try
joining one of you guys because I'm just
curious
you
oh okay
so just as enter his team it's not
giving me an option enter his team
leader oh okay maybe maybe because I'm
the team leader yeah and then you guys
have to Jacob I can leave in the joint
yeah you guys join my instance we'll
even try
see if that works
I don't remember working you actually
live in West Virginia I sure don't it's
on Luke you went there though for this
game I did I did go there for that that
was a crazy event man it's probably one
of the weirdest press trips ever helped
team leader all right show us the NPC
help team leader we've been shown NPC's
throughout this so it totally did not
work this way before right like we would
all just join the mine and we'd all be
in there I don't remember I think so
I don't think there were missions like
this in the Brittain original game where
you would be going in dates is right
like this I feel like we were all just
kind of doing our own thing right who
even knows that was like 40 years ago
kind of feels that way
we should just be picking everything up
right isn't scrapping that's how this
game works I'm not just cuz I don't want
to deal with this guy
so he had shotgun shells Oh nope never
mind
Taylor the gingers wondering how
quarantine is treating you all okay hey
I found Doug I found a guy yeah I'm
doing all right
I miss seeing people in person yeah yeah
here you go here's an NPC who we're all
trying to lead a leader can only I can
talk to him I'm hurting here
weird should I give him a stim pack or
should I lie to him
should you feel it's your stim pack meds
I'll get it's your insolence your
insolence in your stim pack much as I
appreciate it
I'm not the one who needs helping right
now see these scorch things have been
hearing the bar me and my boss says
Holly you got the bright idea to track
down their nest in fear
but a couple of them got the drop on I
heard some fighting but then all right
he's got skin through this you've got to
find Polly we got to find Polly I'll
find him
thank you thank you I've had a sniper
rifle Jay teller Oh give it to me oh I
want that plasma rifle buddy you wanna
do a trade yeah let's do it too bad oh
you jerk can you kill the NPC while I'm
talking to them no that did not seem to
be the case we tried that earlier you
guys are welcome to keep trying every
time if you want that's what the
machetes
yeah this is definitely more interesting
than it used to be this mine agreed oh
hey there's a gold vein down here guys
where what do you do with that well
debate in the center of this room
there's a little walkway there's a gold
vein down here I got a couple cool doors
okay weird yeah I had to like it was a
little finicky and how to where is it
yeah it's at the very bottom you're
looking at it yeah it's like this thing
right here
well I got one there's a couple of them
cuz I'm just at three I got four oh I
see
yeah I got like four there's another one
here oh wow
so much gold but even do with gold
crafting talked it Oh keypad anyone know
the code oh I'm sure there's some note
somewhere down left right left right
okay I start seems good 69 69 69 like
throw up dude do you guys ever playing
console I have this game on xbox
actually but I never played it I I think
cuz that was like one of the codes that
no one took when they sent that can also
happen on xbox left oh hello
now that's the robot oh you happen to
see a young man on your way through
early twelve school peer around the
edges he's alive thank god that's good
to hear
so what do you say you and I help each
other out you get me back to the wayward
and I'll help you bake to a crisp
anything that bothers us on our way out
the door
sounds good nice I got a treasure map
that's the ticket now let's hey guys if
you come up here and there's a treasure
map sounds like route going away ahead
of us here behind you oh I just got a
story leptin
Oh
oh wow okay whoa okay
hey cook cook come up here now we're in
the fight here we're not character on a
carrot like you
not shoot
there we go
it's not all of them I think so there's
a door so we can leave this cave but I
kind of want to find the code for they
keypad okay also if you guys go up there
you'll find your way to a treasure map
yeah this is already way more interested
in the meter pistol there we go oh yeah
chose your mathlete alright I would just
like to say people laughing at our aim
this game does not play well as a
shooter
ooh a flare gun - oh my god
and I think purposely so like I don't
think this is trying to be a no they
were definitely shooter they're
definitely shots where I was like I was
aiming at that person and it just didn't
hit them yeah I think it's doing a like
percentage thing no matter how you're
shooting yeah okay so do we leave do we
try to find that code yeah the quest is
done I can leave now at the code I'm not
really sure it's like this is just back
out so you just want to keep going sure
you got to do it multiple times so we
all can get credit for it right yeah I
wonder if that's the case because it was
saying that so the quests not active
while helping a team leader so were you
guys not doing the quest at all yeah it
still says search going month ago or
that's kind of lame that sucks
that's not great well that is an extreme
bummer
all right well come back I can come back
to later and do some more exploring or
something like that yeah like it alright
started recording uh yeah you guys want
to continue that quest you just want to
well you can't really consider to you I
guess you know I mean yeah
now you keep it then if you want it you
can see where you keep it
see it's a nice nice little gun I got
why do we go find like a town people are
talking about towns yes good idea do you
know we are we have no identity I mean I
see a group of houses people's houses
are like showing up on the people's
camps are showing up on the map now that
feel like that wasn't the case before
let's head over to the north northeast
see boots over there we got a we got a
bad guy I got a drink water too cuz I
saw it was red and I was like oh I must
be bleeding and then I said oh wait yeah
[Music]
that's cool I got some I got some
Brahman melki Matt and I milk two notes
a Brahman earlier whoa yeah oh no Jake
stole all the Brahmin milk for himself
it wasn't very good you don't you
wait wasn't that treasure map somewhere
around here oh you're right
I remember us doing that before yeah I
totally remember those doing that before
let's check it's on this bridge oh
really
like yeah if you look at it I think this
this bridge or another bridge nearby
totally is it up on a tree it looks so
good it might be the other bridge it's
there's a destroyed rail at the end of
it hold on is it this bridge over here
I don't know
yes yes yes okay I found it I'm pretty
sure yep I found it
yeah all right or coming that's because
we did this before I like totally
remember so I think it's like right
there down by the riverbed yeah it
should be like over here
oh I do remember this oh hey there we go
what did I get I got a plan I got a
bolt-action Oh Raider armor a dick tall
but no wives me
hello I got a dick tall no there's
nothing for me oh wait no I bolt-action
a single action alright
[Music]
yeah I got a plan for something pocketed
Rayder our chests well
all right well I wish it told me it was
a little more clear when I got other
than just popping up in the top flap
yeah that doesn't feel that interweave
that was weird
yeah I was expecting like a a crate you
know like one of the many crates you
loot in this game yeah totally
some kind of chests with Treasury
alright so how about we launch a nuke or
something like that I think we can do
that in the next 10 minutes or something
well how long does each battle royale
mode I just want to play that it off
winning the Battle Royale match I have
no idea I'm neither to play that lady
yeah me too I uh I'm actually interested
if that's all about oh this is the town
you went to where if one lined up around
that PC to get the next mission right no
that's uh that's a different town but I
totally know what you're talking about I
just remember a big long line and like
there'd be like a 50% chance that your
game would just crash and you'd be stuck
in there or you couldn't leave Oh
enemies huh
Oh behind me oh hey hey cool oh this
one's got a dinner fork and a silver
bowl wow we can have a whole meal with
these the loot these guys got a nice
silver locket
dang
he's a lock door here I can open unless
I break all my bobby pins yeah if you
break yours I got one left
all right we're good what's it worth it
though Kanna doesn't seem like it
I guess Bourbon empty bourbon or no
there's no you took it all cool oh hey
there's a bowie knife over here you know
I already got a couple it's all yours
all right I'm sorry sorry I did I forgot
that like in World items are per and
then like in chests it's all
free-for-all or what I found a safe but
I don't have the skill for it any of you
oh where is it I can Oh heart right here
we're all interesting alright alright
we're getting somewhere
Oh a boxing glove but you can wear hell
yeah that's a cooler loot than when I
got well I think I'm over encumbered
okay and I set up my camp somewhere so I
can yeah maybe yeah maybe now is a good
point to call it where do we set up how
do we set up camp again so you Paul game
just crashed oh there you go that's the
perfect time the game heard me say it
the stream was kissed Matt you you pull
up your pip-boy and then you can move
your cam all right I gotta find a place
to put it
help me put it right here man a kit
oh you can't oh thank you good what
about over like over there
yeah I gosh alright guys well thank you
for checking out the stream and this
brief little look at the wastelanders
update for Fallout I mean I feel like we
really just scratched the surface of it
I definitely want to go back and kind of
like pay more attention to the dialogue
and I'm super curious to see how much of
this permeates throughout the whole game
like how long is all this new story
stuff you're doing which I guess you'll
get that answer because Jake is gonna do
a cool feature on it yeah are you
planning on getting that up this week or
hopefully this week maybe maybe early
next week okay cool well you can look
forward to that and yeah for anything
else
fallout related or just video game
related you should you should subscribe
to GameSpot Matt tell me why they should
subscribe a GameSpot
it's it's the spot for games and there
are tons of awesome ones yeah also if
they want to join the GameSpot discord
server let us know and we can yes we
have a we have a discord server where a
bunch of lovely people just come in and
hang out and chat with us and chat with
each other and talk about games so if
you want in on that just hit us up on on
Twitter I'm just at John leaks at key I
think Jake is an adze
Jakob deck yep is it and yeah thanks for
watching guys
oh wait I met I met Padgett oh yeah
Matt's not going to give you a discord
invite but that's that's Matt's Twitter
I'll invite you to the secret game no I
don't have a secret
discord guys thanks for watching have a
good one
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]